Backing up your iPhone is a smart idea all around.
It safeguards your important data like pictures and contacts.
And it means you can switch all your info to a brand new device easy-peasy.
There are a number of ways to back up, but here's how you do it on iCloud.
iCloud is a digital home for your data,...
...so you can use it to back up your phone without having to plug it into anything.
Magic!
First off, connect your phone to a Wi-Fi network.
Then, we take a trip from your home screen menu.
Tap Settings, followed by iCloud and Back up.
Make sure the iCloud back up bar shows green, that means it's on...
...and simply tap Back Up Now below.
The process might take a while, but trust us: it's worth the wait.
And all your stuff's stored online.
Yes, even that guilty pleasures playlist.